take off one third of the group Migos is
dead after a fatal shooting in Houston
Texas according to multiple reports
but depressing the ice if you don't know
what that is the Houston Police
Department confirms that a shooting took
place around 2 30 a.m local time at a
bowling alley in Houston and that one
victim was found deceased upon arrival
authorities say that two other victims
were taken to hospitals in private
vehicles but they did not reveal the
identity of the deceased nor the injured
according to TMZ takeoff and cuevo who
was reportedly not harmed during the
incident were playing dice when an
altercation broke out and someone opened
fire shooting and killing takeoff
takeoff was the youngest member of Migos
you know we don't need to know if you
you know I'm saying if you're part of
the culture and a part of hip-hop and
music you need to know you have fuel to
the fire you know I'm saying we love it
make it go harder the band was his
family cuevo his uncle and offset his
cousin all on the one table one table
it's one family then nobody else got
them looking for right right yeah
[Music]
[Music]
just minutes before the shooting takeoff
posted this pick to his insta story
smoking at the venue
ET has reached out to Houston Police
Migos and takeoff's Reps for comment
I can't even believe that it is true
[Music]
stuff following the news
stars were quick
ER quick social media it's crazy
gotta take care of yourselves take care
of your friends stop this stupid stupid
Madness it's just dumb Christina Milian
shared an emotional message writing that
she was definitely a fan young Miami
tweeting three heartbreak emojis while
Tiana Taylor shared a pic of the rapper
begging for the news to just be a bad
dream
thank you
[Music]